welcome to this video playing Thomas
Tallis Thomas Tallis ok Kings Indian I
guess nope this is not so bad 93 an
interesting sideline now is giving me
the bishop pair for zip and pip I like
that yeah White has a good development
yeah definitely but still should be
quite ok what so what he's saying is
that he wants to take on her seven right
97 he wants to take on your 7 this is
working or not it takes twice 95 at the
end maybe maybe it's not completely
ridiculous ok before I lose on time we
are figuring that out let's just play
something
chan chap 95 de maybe yeah seems to be
playable for him I can give the check
and queen age three words don't know c5
also possible I can let's take spending
far too much time on that as usual could
have easily played those more than 20
seconds here so this is the problem
sometimes keep thinking about some some
lines here and there and it's not really
necessary to do can just just play
normal moves and be okay and sometimes
that you should just play the the normal
move that I can play in 20 seconds and
be okay with it okay yeah doubling on
the D file is kind of normal Luke g7 and
so on he aged 5 he can really go chief
FOIA this is something that I probably
don't want okay let's just double I'm
not going to get checkmated so quickly
him would be I would be surprised if he
just can play age 5 and and stuff taking
g for Queen edge to this kind of caveman
style
yeah well here's the moment where I can
take on e4 for just for just being okay
but the question is is there more oh
come on let's do that keep it simple go
into f2 and so on in this kind of
opposite colored bishop scenario is
never going to check made me the bishop
on g7 is always keeping things protected
and this this pressure on the D how also
keeps them at bay a little bit but it's
not that I'm better or anything I cannot
cannot do much it's no refutation of his
play or something something like that
maybe I'm threatening looked for here
why not really can go to e3
okay just just going back oh I thought
you would just he just wanted wow I
thought you just wanted two coordinators
his pieces a little better but he really
wants to do this kind of attack hey okay
so look T for again can check that out
Queenie three though am it's not really
all right I can still play it and ask
him basically what what he's doing
or queen d525 is also not better just
just trading yeah okay let's do that why
not it's it's simple and good
I have this g5 idea oh yeah even a
little bit better it's not enough to win
but check and I will try
I wanted to try to win but it's
impossible wanted to go Bishop evade and
then play for f 5m I cannot do that
unfortunately
hmm jab oh it's okay badly again this is
a really bad play at the moment what I'm
doing here now I even have to be
somewhat careful not to lose which is
really a bit embarrassing from from this
kind of development of the game
okay well this is this is just a dead
draw but he's got one minute more on the
clock time morning this is a total
blockade on the dark squares this is
better right dra I heard it's a bit
cheeky with a minute down in the clock
but it's really a complete draw can
really I just have to stay on the
diagonals on this one on the other one
and the king is blocking the King side
is really no way forward it's a complete
draw okay he decides he wants to try to
win on time dra Arthur no gain it's okay
you can play a couple of moves and think
about it but it's really totally dead I
can just stay here covering covering
this somehow I cannot examine here no I
can I'm covering here and he has no way
forward he can do this this I just stay
here I keep b6 protected and the king
and porn are keeping the King side I was
thinking I mean should be really better
in this and gave me a little bit but
probably i'm not i was thinking that I
could maybe maybe manage this kind of
thing and then f5 but it's not it's not
working I have to get this in it by the
time he enters with his King as we have
seen so there is no way a way forward in
this end game yeah so this was a little
bit this was a little bit unassuming
then check chat ok I mean the easy way
for draw is just just to take it of
course and then there's absolutely
nothing happening but in the opening
this is kind of weird what did happen
here ok the computer is giving c5 with
an advantage yeah i was i was thinking
about it briefly that the idea is that
this is not good yeah tactics but i
wasn't sure about stuff on f7 happening
i mean well i wasn't sure it's probably
still the best move this is this is
funnier this is what i wanted to do
originally but yeah yeah this is very
embarrassing or i go here check check
check
checkmate yeah these kind of things yeah
well this is just okay but it's nothing
special I cannot really refute this
chill and here I mean I'm okay nothing
nothing special but nothing nothing bad
at bad either this is this is what's
better according to the computer that's
quite quite interesting if white is
taking it wants to get this big play on
the diagonal in quite interesting plant
sacrifice okay well I hope you enjoyed
the game thanks for watching